this is 10 micrograms you think that I
might be able to see I think you might
be able to oh boy it's an arrow right
there yeah yeah the flashlight will help
I feel like I need to to get video of
this I don't know how it kind of looks
like a hair like a tiny like a smaller
than an eyelash
if you want to measure a force like the
weight of an object the way it has
always been done has been to balance it
with some known standards and the most
precise standard weight people ever
created was the kilogram of platinum
iridium cylinder stored in a vault on
the outskirts of Paris
replicas of this kilogram were sent to
countries around the world to use as
their Mass standards here is k-20 the
United States Mass standard and yes the
U.S is secretly metric they just apply a
conversion factor to get to Freedom
Units it's just a little translation
that we do here but our country is
actually on the metric system doesn't
that seem crazy yes it's stupid
the uncertainty in the mass of a
standard kilogram is on the order of
tens of micrograms so that's tens of
parts per billion or about point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent it's
pretty good
but there's a problem if you want to
weigh something lighter than a kilogram
the uncertainty increases this little
object here is a 50 gram test weight so
it's a reference Mass can I pick it up
with tweezers yeah you don't mind sure
we try to keep the fingerprints off
so it's got a little bit of heft you can
feel that a little yeah
what about this one what's this this is
10 grams here
yeah that's pretty light that's pretty
light and paper clip here is about one
gram
and so how you might use one of these
test masses so if you're you know
working in a laboratory or something
like that you could take one of these
little weights and put it on here and
you could look at the scale and say oh
okay my scale is reasonably well
calibrated here that last digit might
you know change a little bit but you
could sort of make some statement about
whether or not your scale is accurate
when we're talking about the kilogram
you know these are obviously much
smaller than a kilogram you know how do
we you know think about getting from
that large object down to something
that's you know this size here
one of the ways to do it is using
conventional Mass Metrology which is
that you take the kilogram and you use a
process called subdivision where you
compare other smaller masses against the
kilogram you take two 500 gram masses
and you make sure that they're equal on
your balance right and then you you put
both of those on your balance and
compare that against a kilogram would
you go like two 500s and then two 250s
and then 2 125s like you just yeah yeah
yeah so you could do like one of the one
common Arrangement is something like we
have here this is a 500 milligram mess
these are two uh 200 milligram masses
and that's a 100 milligram Mass so these
three sum up to this okay right so you
can compare those two against each other
the smallest we have here
is down there that's a milligram
that is a milligram that is a milligram
right there what are they made out of
these are made out of stainless steel
and we have to do things like you see
this little lint-free brush here you
know if you have a speck of dust on here
or something like that it can be can be
a problem if it's a big Speck of dust
you know so so every time we do wangs
with these you know we'll take a a
lint-free cloth and a brush and clean
them off a little bit why are they these
this sort of curious wire kind of shape
the shapes yeah it helps you remember
which one is which you know the
five-sided one is five 500 milligrams
you know one of the interesting things
from from my perspective about this is
that you can you can really subdivide
over a large range of these masses from
a kilogram you know this is one
millionth of a kilogram is a is a
milligram so you can subdivide the
kilogram by a million times you know the
but you sort of pay a price for that
because each time you do this
subdivision the uncertainty increases a
little bit right so what is the
uncertainty and say the milligram there
uh if you do it with a subdivision it
will be uh maybe a part in 10 to the
four one part and ten to the four so
like uh 0.01 percent ish range but there
is a way to do better and that's thanks
to the fact that kilogram is no longer
defined by the Platinum iridium cylinder
in Paris over the course of a century or
so the replica kilograms were brought
back to Paris a few times to be weighed
with each other and from those
measurements it became clear that their
weights were diverging by up to 75
micrograms no one could say if the
replicas were getting heavier or if the
original was getting lighter but it was
unacceptable to have mass standards with
changing masses so the solution was to
eliminate the kilograms dependence on a
physical object and instead Define it
based on a constant of nature Planck's
constant so how does that work well
Planck's constant is best known for
relating the frequency of a photon to
its energy by E equals HF but energy and
mass are related through E equals Mt
squared so you can see how mass is
related to Planck's constant in 2019
scientists officially set the value of
Planck's constant to be this number in
Joule seconds which along with the
definition of the meter and the second
now defines what a kilogram is
the real advantage of this definition is
how it can be applied in fancy scales
this is a kibble balance it can balance
the weight of an object with an
electromagnetic force what's great about
that is that the electrical quantities
used in this balance can be read out
very accurately and in units of Planck's
constant so you get direct traceability
by weighing something in this balance
this is kind of the smaller cousin of
the kibble balance it's called the
electrostatic force balance or the efb
and this is a this is a balance that was
designed specifically to measure mass
sort of in the milligram range the
kibble balance uses an electromagnet I
use a capacitor which is basically two
metal electrodes that you apply a
potential to and when you apply a
potential there's an attractive Force
between those two electrodes I apply an
electrostatic force by applying a
voltage here at this you can see this
cylinder here there is this cylinder and
there's inside of this there's another
cylinder in there close together so you
have this concentric cylinder like this
and when you apply a voltage it pulls
that moving cylinder down in there and
by measuring the properties of the
capacitor and measuring the voltage that
we apply we can know exactly how much
force we get here
and then up here we drop our Mass on so
we compare our gravitational force from
the mass to the electrostatic force from
our capacitor to get the best accuracy
this lab is located deep underground and
they keep the air temperature a constant
20 degrees Celsius to avoid any thermal
expansion or contraction of the devices
and all measurements in this balance are
made in a vacuum so there are no air
currents and no buoyant force on the
object from the atmosphere they've even
carefully measured the acceleration due
to gravity in the lab here it is it's
under the chair
right there that triangle that is where
the USGS measured absolute gravity with
an absolute gravimeter 9.801 ish meters
per second does this lab measure small
forces the most accurately in the world
at the milligram level so 10 Micro
Newtons ish of course yes this measures
Force the most accurately in the world
I'm confident in saying that but of
course you know you can go lower than
that this is the smallest weight and you
can't see it here this is 10 micrograms
so when you think about the uncertainty
in in a kilogram when you take Planck's
constant at a kibble balance and you
realize the kilogram you're at that
level of about 10 micrograms and that is
what 10 micrograms I mean you can't I I
had to put the little arrow here so you
can if you were here in the laboratory
you could look and peer down there maybe
I feel like I need to to get video of
this so people can see what 10
micrograms you know I I don't know how
it kind of looks like a hair like a tiny
like a smaller than an eyelash right
yeah much thinner yeah that's about the
scale you're looking at there yeah I'm
almost certain I can capture this on
video we brought a special lens with us
oh we brought a special special lens 20
24 mil macro because I was like we're
gonna need it for this
thing
well I can see it ah yes do you see it
there yeah yeah yeah yeah you got it
you made this yes with great trouble and
then calibrated it on a balance it was
man I'll tell you it was not easy when
you have that thing you know you can
imagine what it's like trying to work
with something like this right and this
is about as small as you can reasonably
expect to make something as a test
weight
and if you want to measure a force
smaller than that so I have these little
tiny chips here these are Atomic Force
microscope cantilevers they're a little
tiny Force sensors on the end of these
they're little tiny cantilever beams
with a sharp tip and you can use that
sharp tip to to press against things and
apply Nano Newton to Pico Newton forces
but I mean the tip is so small though
it's very very difficult to see you it
really requires a microscope is it like
there's a little diving board yeah
exactly there's a little diving board
that's right it looks like a little
diving board it's like a spring right
and if you push on it the more it bends
the larger the force what is the
smallest force that you want to measure
yeah I can show you I can show you uh
this is one of the sensors we used to do
the smallest forces that I can
confidently say we've measured that are
traceable in some way to the the
International System of Units
um and that is uh femto Newtons of force
at about a Pico Newton which would be
like if you're stretching out a DNA
molecule so if you take a DNA molecule
and stretch it out and and that's a
piconewton so back to a factor of a
thousand less than that was what we were
measuring so you know this is an example
of one of the sensors we use to get to
the sort of femto Newton level this is a
few silica parallelogram flexor you
can't see it really well so let me I
have a big big version right here so
what we can do is we can set this
vibrating
and it'll vibrate with a really pure
tone and we can see very very small
changes in force based on how how far
this vibrates up and down I would have a
little laser interferometer which
measures the motion of this so we
measure the displacement of this end
here and then right next to it would
have a little tiny optical fiber that
would deliver a known Optical laser
power to this so this would be a photon
pressure Force whereby reflecting the
light off the surface here we actually
get a very small Force if we vary that
that Force sinusoidality we vary it in
time we can get this to move up and down
and we can get it to vibrate and we can
see differences as small as uh as femto
Newtons in in our Force so you're saying
you could measure the force from a laser
pointer yeah oh yeah yeah definitely
yeah you've done that we're shining on
that that's right that's that's about uh
about about approximately seven
piconewtons of force once again you know
that that's enough to stretch out a DNA
molecule
can I ask you the big questions yeah
yeah why does anyone need to measure
forces this month that's a good question
so a couple of things you know there are
a couple of different answers to that
one is sort of the industrial relevance
Automotive manufacturers need to measure
the mass of particulates that come off
their exhaust particularly in diesel
systems particulate contamination is
really kind of a big a big deal so you
need to be able to measure 50 micrograms
of these particulates for those
environmental standards to be that the
laser power measurements for people who
are doing industrial processes with
lasers because you can actually use the
measurement of a small Force to
calibrate laser power you know
Pharmaceuticals you know you have
milligram doses microgram doses
sometimes the other thing that's
important I think kind of goes to the
heart of why nist is so cool in my
opinion is that it really helps us push
the frontiers of science the scientific
new scientific discoveries benefit from
the new measurement capabilities which
then feed into new Precision Metrology
capabilities and so that is really one
of the things to me that makes nist
really special is that we're very good
at sort of creating that environment
where that can happen
[Applause]
if you like me are fascinated by
Precision measurement then I bet you
would love the sponsor of this video
brilliant brilliant is a learning tool
that helps you master stem Concepts like
foundational math computer science and
quantum physics it's full of interactive
Hands-On lessons that build on each
other you don't just get an introduction
to a subject you actually understand it
at a deep level and that's because you
practice it and answer questions to test
your knowledge you can try their
interactive lessons for free right now
by going to brilliant.org veritasium and
I would recommend a great place to start
is their course on scientific thinking
there you solve real world puzzles using
scientific principles like gears or
balances and if you want to dig deeper
into forces at the nanoscale you can
learn about how proteins fold and unfold
and connect that to how energy relates
to chemical bonds with questions
throughout the lesson it's way more
engaging than just watching or reading
and if you ever get stuck helpful hints
are always close at hand I also love
their quantum mechanics course because
it's totally accessible but it doesn't
hold back on teaching Quantum State
calculations and practical experiments
in fact you can follow how scientists
design sensitive measurements using
light just like Dr Shaw there's an
entire section on designing your own
setup to measure quantum entanglement
using polarizers on an optical table I
love working with brilliant because I
think it's the perfect complement to
science videos my goal is to get you
interested in a topic and then if you
want to learn more you can use brilliant
to practice and master the material and
now that we're in the holiday season if
you're looking for an easy fun gift for
friends or family who love learning try
a brilliant subscription they have
thousands of lessons and new exclusive
releases every month and if you sign up
for yourself or someone else right now
brilliant are offering 20 off an annual
premium subscription to the first 200
people just use my link brilliant.org
veritasium I will put that link down in
the description so I want to thank
brilliant for sporting veritasium and I
want to thank you for watching